[Music]
so when i was 14 years old my father had
passed away and when his best friend
brought his belongings back to my house
neither none of my family knew but i
actually had my fingerprint in his phone
so
i opened up his phone and i was going
through his photos and i found
photos of other women who
i think he was cheating on my mom with
he was trying to take you know gross
photos of women at these bars and i saw
that he had contacts of all these like
random women with different area codes
so i deleted all of the photos because i
didn't want
anyone in my family including my mom to
be
hurt by these things since he was
already gone
my secret is that i've never been asked
out before
i don't think i'm an unattractive man
but
i've always been doing the asking in my
life no one's ever asked for my number
or to dance or to go out
i don't know
it would be nice
[Music]
i recently recovered some
childhood memories of my dad sexually
abusing me it's weird because even
though i forgot and like my brain
kind of
protected me from remembering that i
feel like my body always knew and
remembering all of it and
like telling people has
just been this huge weight off my
shoulders it just feels like i've been
holding this secret for so long that i
didn't realize i was holding
[Music]
my secret is
i miss all the compliments i would get
when i had my worst relationship with
food
[Music]
when i moved overseas i hate the fact
that i'm mormon for years because i was
afraid of what people would think of me
[Music]
i was a homeless drug addict for six
years
[Music]
um i am
just learning to identify as non-binary
and i'm i think i might be gender fluid
if it feels really weird to say out loud
i've never said that out loud before but
[Music]
i try to show myself as being
an outgoing person who is
strong in my beliefs but really i'm
quite anxious and
socially awkward most of the time and
it's
it's all a farce i would say
[Music]
okay so my secret is
that i pretend to be stronger than i am
and
i can't wait till i just start to be a
little nicer to myself
less self-deprecating thoughts and just
go with the flow and learn to be like
one with other people instead of
expecting so much and
constantly feeling like it's not the way
i want things to be
[Music]
i've never had a boyfriend because major
attachment issues from
my father and him not really showing me
any real affection so not really been
comfortable having that sort of
affection from a guy and being loved
from a guy bye guy
my deepest darkest secret is
i cried off the piglets movie
[Music]
so we've never talked about it
explicitly but um
i'm my parents favorite of the three
sons and both of my brothers know it and
it's always been a bone of contention
[Music]
i got a blood on my butt
[Music]
i had a crush on my cousin when i was in
middle school
i'm scared that when i go to real
university after being in community
college for three years that i'm going
to fail everything
[Music]
so my secret is i wrote a love letter to
a guy and it was right before he was
about to move away and i put it in a
pocket of his luggage and i told him to
let me know if he ever found it
so he either hasn't found it or read it
and didn't feel the same and never
responded
[Music]
the thing that first comes to mind when
i think of a secret that i don't
typically share with people is the fact
that i don't believe in god but at the
same time i'm super superstitious so
like i totally get kind of freaked out
when i think about splitting the poll
when i'm walking with someone
seeing certain numbers and just
believing in what they could represent
and how it could affect me i think it
also could be connected to my anxiety
honestly but not quite sure still
something i'm trying to work out with
myself but just think it's something
that a secret i guess
[Music]
okay so my secret is i'm one of those
adults known as a falls adult fan of
lego
and i remember my first encounter with
legos was when we moved to the u.s
we moved from guadalajara
and we got happy meals and i was like
what's a happy meal and mine came with
some legos and just these tiny little
lego sets and ever since then i've
always like always play with legos still
play with legos now build with them
share with my son and we're a lego
family my wife loves them too so that
was cool maybe that could be the secret
that's when i knew i was going to marry
her i was like she's like i want to have
a lego room and i was like yes marry me
now
so
yup legos for life
so i like walk away like in the sunset
like john wayne
so we've been really good friends for
about five years now
but we usually don't tell people that we
kind of met in a cult we didn't think it
was a cult at first until we got out i
guess but happily um this place where we
met does not exist anymore because like
any other religious
cult the leader
though
the leader was sexually assaulting the
students
so and once that came out students
finally started talking about how crazy
it was like there was this thing we had
to do that was like a boot camp where
they give you what we ate like 500
calories a day while you're there you
like run around this obstacle course and
if you like don't know your bible verses
no a bible verse like you say the like
though when you shouldn't say that like
you have to jump in this like dirty
little pond that like says no swimming
because it's like a health concern
or if you were able to stay through
the night
you would have to do this thing where
you would pretend to be a baby
and
you would have to like be fed like
water or like what is it it was they
would play the sound of a baby at night
in the middle of the night multiple
random times
and everyone had to go and like take
care of their fake baby and if you
didn't
then you were like punished somehow it
was basically like just to intentionally
deprive you of sleep yes you also like
weren't allowed to like brush your teeth
or wear deodorant yeah and you didn't
know when it was going to end right one
of the girls that we lived with would
literally pull my shirt up to see if i
was wearing a safety shirt
underneath which is like safety because
that's how you keep boys safe boys safe
from like going to hell or something
right oh yeah the lady in charge of it
would have students go even though she
was like an hour away to clean her house
yeah on a regular basis i regretted her
whole bathroom she made people rake her
carpet who rakes a [ __ ] carpet sorry
i don't know if i'm supposed f-word
so um i guess the lesson here is
maybe don't go to like bible colleges
yeah maybe don't go maybe don't go to
bible colleges
but i mean if you do go you might get a
really great friend out of it or at
least find out if it's like a real one a
real one you know you know not a cultish
one yeah but yeah it was such a moment
caused a lot of trauma
and but i have a really great friend and
a really amazing therapist same i love
therapy i love it so much
and you i love
[Music]
you hey everyone for those of you who
are new my name is thoria and i'm the
girl behind the camera make sure to
subscribe and hit the notification bell
so you'll be notified every time i have
a new episode up and follow me on
instagram i'll be posting more on there
as always thank you guys for everything
i love you all and i'll see you next
time
[Music]